[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est sens public votre
rendez-vous quotidien de débat et de
reportage sur Public Sénat comme tous
les soirs du lundi au jeudi à 18h et 22h
on donne du sens à l'actualité grâce à
nos experts et voici le sommaire de ce
23 février Jean-Luc Mélenchon est-il en
train de fracturer la gauche la
stratégie de LFI sur la réforme des
retraites a fini par lasser ses alliés
politiques et exaspéré les leaders
syndicaux on va décortiquer les raisons
de l'isolement de celui qui rassemblait
son camp il y a 10 mois seulement avec
près de 7 millions de voix à la
présidentielle et puis pour notre second
débat on continue de faire le bilan d'un
an de guerre en Ukraine un conflit qui
frappe aussi les civils près de 20 000
morts et blessés
comment peux-tu te sentir bien quand
quelqu'un meurt tous les jours quand mes
amis dans d'autres villes écrivent
qu'ici une bombe est tombée que là-bas
quelqu'un est mort que là-bas un
camarade de classe a été tué comment
peux-tu te sentir bien bien sûr ça n'est
pas agréable mais la vie continue et il
faut continuer à vivre
la situation militaire est-elle figée
aujourd'hui quel armes
occidentales sont livrées en ce moment
quels sont les ressorts de
l'extraordinaire résistant ukrainienne
réponse dans trois quarts d'heure mais
d'abord quand Jean-Luc Mélenchon sème la
zizanie dernier épisode le conseil
politique des insoumis appelle
solennellement les sénateurs de la nu
pas faire à tout faire pour empêcher
l'adoption de la retraite à 64 ans
comment vous dire ils n'ont pas vraiment
apprécié la leçon d'opposition Hugo
Lemonnier
il n'a plus de mandat mais reste
omniprésent Jean-Luc Mélenchon continue
de concentrer les critiques adressées à
la France insoumise exemple lorsque elle
est fit demande au sénateur de gauche de
tout faire pour empêcher l'adoption de
la retraite à 7 ans la réaction est
immédiate dans les rangs socialistes
nous n'avons rien demandé à Jean-Luc
Mélenchon et nous l'avons pas attendu
nous ne sommes pas non plus des
idiots qui attend donc son oracle tombe
nous regardons par contre comment être
le plus utile possible pour accompagner
et soutenir le mouvement social la
stratégie d'obstruction adoptée par la
France insoumise à l'Assemblée à laisser
des traces au sein de la nupesse en
témoigne l'embarras de la députée
écologiste Sandrine Rousseau
je n'ai pas partagé je ne suis pas
certaine qu'on puisse mener un combat
comme aussi important que celui des
retraites en étant sur une stratégie qui
soit isolée parce que le que ce soit
Philippe Martinez ou Laurent Berger ou
nous au sein de nanux nous avions pour
idée d'aller à cet article 7 d'en
discuter puisque c'était le cœur de la
réforme et que probablement nous le
devions quand même aux citoyens citoyens
du côté des organisations syndicales
colère froide de Laurent Berger il y a
des millions de citoyens de travailleurs
qui manifestent plusieurs jours durant
contre le rapport de l'âge
principalement à 64 ans et la
représentation nationale ne débat pas de
ce sujet là c'est un double problème je
vous dis le premier problème c'est un
délai contraint on peut pas avoir un
délai contraint en termes de procédure
parlementaire sur un sujet aussi
important que les que ce que cette
réforme de retraite le deuxième problème
c'est le comportement de certains
députés notamment de la France insoumise
qui ont considéré que l'obstruction
était plus contre la vie de tous les
organisations syndicales étaient plus
bénéfiques que d'aller à l'article 7 en
réaction Jean-Luc Mélenchon a appelé à
oublier des propos diviseurs remercions
les députés qui ont de la retraite à 64
ans
[Musique]
soutenez Jean-Luc Mélenchon il y avait
eu cette une la gauche c'est lui si je
me souviens bien
en effet est-ce que vous êtes déçu
aujourd'hui
déçu non enfin je peux pas vraiment dire
ça parce que pour être déçu faut tout
attendre pour beaucoup attendre Jean-Luc
Mélenchon avait réussi à rassembler
l'essentiel de la gauche et c'est pour
ça qu'on l'avait d'ailleurs soutenu à
l'époque parce qu'il était le candidat
qui s'imposait à toute la gauche mais on
sait quand même pour ceux qui suivent la
vie politique que Jean-Luc Mélenchon est
quand même à Monsieur tréversatile et
que il change de point de vue il y a 8
ans il y a 10 ans il quitte le parti
socialiste pour créer le Parti de Gauche
et maintenant il a Goni et les parties
et la gauche il revendique le bruit et
la fureur et en même temps il se prévaut
de Jaurès et de Mitterrand c'est à dire
qu'en fait il manie les choses au gré du
vent au gré des circonstances avec assez
peu de Constance là en ce moment il est
comme en 2017 à l'issue des élections où
il avait rassemblé déjà beaucoup de
monde 18%, il est dans une politique de
rupture et de clash il nettoie une
étoile paysage une étoile paysage il a
dégagé on ne se souvient il y a quelques
semaines quelques mois tous ceux qui à
l'intérieur du parti n'étaient pas
forcément ses opposants mais simplement
risqué de lui faire ombre pour sa
stratégie personnelle de retour
aux affaires au premier plan et donc
Raquel Garrido Alexis Corbière Ruffin
clémentinota Coquerel en ont fait des
frais et maintenant c'est avec les
alliés entre guillemets de la nupes
qu'il est très très indélicat et avec
l'ensemble des syndicats aussi donc
c'est un monsieur qui échangeant et des
fois il rassemble et des fois ils
clivent et là il est dans une séquence
il clean vrai X avec qui comment vous
analysez cette cette mauvaise passe
est-ce que il y a une stratégie
Mélenchon effectivement
il y a peut-être des comment dire des
tactiques et par contre une stratégie
constante c'est quand même assez peu
lisible enfin ça dépend si on parle que
de la stratégie à propos de la réforme
des retraites on est en plus général
plus généralement ce qui est curieux
c'est que Jean-Luc Mélenchon a décidé de
ne pas se représenter aux élections
législatives donc se mettre en retrait
et de ne pas être en mesure de peser en
tout cas directement sur l'organisation
de son groupe au moment même où son
groupe passe quand même rappelons-le de
15 à 75 députés ça multiplication par 5
c'est quand même très très important on
n'est plus dans la même configuration
l'autre ambiguïté c'est que vous vous
souvenez que peu après l'élection
présidentielle annoncée qu'il ne
brillerait pas à nouveau mandat en tout
cas une quatrième candidature laissant
le soin
au fond à son organisation de faire
naître un peu je ne sais pas comment à
nouveau ou une nouvelle leader donc là
tout en restant présent au fond il
brouille le message c'est-à-dire qu'on
ne sait pas très très bien finalement
quel est son statut est-ce que ça doit
être un grand sage qui prend du recul ou
est-ce que ça doit être quelqu'un qui
doit continuer à intervenir donc
effectivement cette versatilité moi je
la je la lis pas en fonction de la
psychologie de Mélenchon mais par
rapport à la difficulté qu'il a
finalement de bien savoir ce qu'il veut
c'est à dire et je pense que ce qui
s'est passé aussi ces derniers mois
c'est qu'il a un peu perdu le contrôle
quand même sur son groupe il y a eu
l'affaire Catena ce qu'il a quand même
considérablement affaibli puisque
c'était son poulain
il a ensuite essayé de pousser Emmanuel
Bompard à prendre la suite mais il était
beaucoup moins consensuel beaucoup des
nouveaux députés élus sous la bannière
LFI ne sont pas aussi redevables que les
la première génération vis-à-vis de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon ils ont été élus
grâce à la nupesse il le savent ils ont
pas été élus simplement parce que
Mélenchon a fait un bon score élection
présidentielle parce que ils étaient
candidat uniques ils ont bénéficié et je
pense qu'il y a moins cette comment dire
cette soumission cette dévotion qui
avait avant et Jean-Luc Mélenchon le
sang sans doute et donc essaye malgré
tout de de peser pied un troisième
problème qui est un problème constant
depuis très longtemps avec les filles et
Jean-Luc Mélenchon c'est son rapport aux
organisations syndicales alors ça on y
reviendra donc
[Musique]
au cœur aussi de la de la polémique on
est de cette séquence et de cette
séquence évidemment et ça on y reviendra
en détail Pascal Perrino effectivement
le c'est plus difficile bah c'est un peu
basique ce que je vais dire mais de
peser sur un groupe quand on y siège pas
si enfin voilà si on parle de de la
relation de pouvoir entre Jean-Luc
Mélenchon et les députés ne serait-ce
que seulement les députés elle est fille
déjà c'est c'est une vraie erreur
stratégique qu'il a qui l'a certainement
une erreur stratégique de ne pas s'être
représenté parce que on l'a vu dans le
débat sur la réforme des retraites ça
s'est passé c'est beaucoup dans la rue
mais ça c'est beaucoup passé également à
l'Assemblée nationale et donc la voix de
Mélenchon n'était qu'une voie indirecte
et on avait l'impression qu'il était
toujours à la marge en train de corriger
telle ou telle attitude de telle ou tel
député du groupe mais surtout je crois
que Jean-Luc Mélenchon a fait croire à
la lune il a fait croire à la lune il a
fait croire que la gauche était
puissante en France la gauche quand vous
prenez ça sous la 5e République c'est
une de ces périodes les plus affaiblies
quand vous regardez les enquêtes de
pignon aujourd'hui à peu près un
français sur 400 de gauche donc on a on
est dans un niveau extrêmement bas pour
la gauche il a fait croire qu'il y avait
une union de la gauche mais la nuit pèse
c'est pas une union de la gauche une
union de la gauche c'est quand toutes
les familles ont une capacité à
présenter leurs candidats et ensuite au
second tour les électeurs de gauche vont
vers le candidat qui a été choisi au
premier tour par ce qu'on appelait jadis
le peuple de gauche là du peste c'est
quoi c'est une mise sous influence de la
France insoumise des appareils
traditionnels de la gauche le Parti
socialiste et
et donc il était inévitable que tout ça
j'allais dire éclate bien sûr les
socialistes reprennent les socialistes
attendaient ils se retrouvent pas du
tout dans les trois quarts des positions
des défis même chose pour les
écologistes donc chacun reprend reprend
ses billes et d'ailleurs c'était
sensible dès le début quand les
socialistes et les écologistes ont dit
mais n'est pas question d'un groupe
unique nups nous vous avons chacun notre
groupe puis un vague intergroupe qui qui
est là juste pour la pour la façade et
pour la cosmétique donc Jean-Luc
Mélenchon voilà il a fait croire aussi
qu'il était qui pouvait devenir Premier
ministre enfin tout le monde savait très
bien à commencer par lui qui n'était pas
question qu'ils deviennent Premier
ministre donc ça fait beaucoup
d'illusions pour cette gauche et puis
c'est une couche tout à fait
particulière parce que la gauche elle
s'est toujours rassemblée quand il y
avait un centre de gravité à cette
gauche et centre de gravité c'est elle
partie soci
et puis avant le Parti radical est
radical socialiste sous la Troisième
République là voilà c'est une gauche à
l'extrême des familles de la gauche et
il y a jamais eu d'union durable quand
c'est un parti extrême qui voilà cherche
à organiser le combat de l'ensemble de
la gauche on va y revenir évidemment
mais je voudrais avec vous Mathilde
qu'on s'intéresse peut-être un peu plus
à la à la personnalité de gens du
Mélenchon comment vous expliquer ce
désamour croissant de la gauche
vis-à-vis de lui alors nous assistons
Thomas à une sorte de
démêlant sonisation des esprits j'ai
réussi à le dire vous aimez le risque
parce que ce écrire ça dans sa chronique
c'était c'était aux et bravo en quelques
sortes un processus qui pourrait prendre
de l'ampleur et qui révèle les
faiblesses d'un chef de partie on l'a
dit en perte de vitesse il faut dire que
le triple candidat à la présidentielle
est capable des meilleurs coups de génie
on se souvient de sa formule Élisée moi
Premier ministre au sortir de la
présidentielle comme des pires coups de
sang la République c'est moi c'était en
2018 on s'en souvient Jean-Luc Mélenchon
c'est la démographie la démocratie et le
peuple en étendard tout en gérant son
parti plus ou moins comme une dictature
et pour comprendre ces dérives il faut
aller voir du côté de ses inspirations
l'insoumis en chef aime les leaders
charismatiques autoritaires on trouve
dans son panthéon personnel Robespierre
évidemment mais aussi l'ancien président
du Venezuela Hugo Chavez ou encore
fidèle Castro j'en ai fait Longchamp est
favorable à l'Union à condition bien sûr
qu'elle soit à son service or si la
réussite à bâtir la nuque une alliance
électorale bien fragile il a commis
l'erreur on l'a dit de se placer en
surplomb de ne pas se représenter et
tout en voulant continuant à tirer les
ficelles à l'Assemblée et difficile en
réalité d'imposer sa ligne à coup de
tweets et résultat la nu plus échappe et
même son propre groupe de 75 députés
insoumis alors est-ce qu'on peut
imaginer ce que serait elle est fille et
la gauche sans Mélenchon alors on
imagine que Jean-Luc Mélenchon va tout
faire pour tenter de retrouver le
contrôle on sait qu'il a de la ressource
mais il doit désormais gérer des
frondeurs la rupture avec Alexis
Corbière un historique de sa garde
rapprochée en elle l'illustration il
entretient le doute aussi sur une
quatrième candidature en 2017 mais en
réalité
2027 pardon autour vers le futur en fait
c'est un petit peu ça et en réalité on
voit bien que sa succession est dans
toutes les têtes c'est François Ruffin
qui dit qu'il n'exclut pas de se
présenter un jour Clémentine autant qui
a fait savoir qu'elle serait partie
prenante pour la prochaine élection
présidentielle et à gauche il n'a plus
le monopole de la radicalité en témoigne
la place caprice Sandrine Rousseau qui
d'ailleurs n'hésite plus à le défier on
écoute Sandrine
je pense qu'il va que ça signe un peu la
fin d'un acte 1 de la nuit Pesse qui a
fonctionné jusqu'à présent qui était
issu de l'élection présidentielle et que
maintenant nous passons nous devons
passer à un acte 2 lequel acte 2 doit
être fait essentiellement enfin d'abord
à mon avis au sein de l'assemblée et
puis après on verra ce que les parties
souhaitent faire mais en tous les cas au
sein de l'assemblée je pense qu'il va
falloir revoir en effet comment manière
dont nous fonctionnons en faisant en
sorte qu'il y ait une coordination qui
prenne des décisions avec des quelque
chose qui soit beaucoup plus finalement
claire et démocratique j'ai envie de
dire si
au sein de la nuque c'est pas une
question d'hégémonie c'est une question
de vouloir
continuer sur la ligne de LFI elle est
finie enfin je pense qu'il y a une
différence entre LFI et la nuance
voilà cette hégémonie alors reste à
savoir si c'est la gauche contestataire
et protestataire qui la conservera ou au
contraire si le retrait du tribun
Mélenchon petit à petit ouvrira un
nouvel espace pour la gauche et
notamment la gauche de gouvernement et
permet pour permettre le retour d'une
offre plutôt sociale démocrate c'est le
pari par exemple d'un Bernard Cazeneuve
merci beaucoup Mathilde Catherine tricot
est-ce que Sandrine Rousseau combien
l'entendre elle incarne pas finalement
la nouvelle forme de radicalité plus
moderne que celle de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
certainement c'est pas tout à fait sur
les mêmes sont les mêmes sujets mais moi
vous avez donc vous avez pas dans votre
chronique complémentaire aussi sont
d'autres façons de d'incarner une
certaine radicalité ce que je crois
c'est que Jean-Luc Mélenchon a réussi à
rassembler 22% sur son nom pas sur une
ligne justement de bruit et de fureur
c'est précisément parce que c'est un
caméléon qui est capable de se mettre
dans la position du rassembleur de toute
la gauche vous avez raison de dire que
la gauche est très faible mais même dans
cette faiblesse c'est lui qui a réussi
sur une position relativement claire de
rupture avec le bilan de de Hollande
quand bien même ça ferait de la peine à
Bernard Cazeneuve c'est quand même
plutôt sur ce point-là que la gauche se
retrouve aujourd'hui en gommant un peu
ce que vous dites le bruit et la fureur
pendant sa campagne présidentielle c'est
très clairement la campagne de
l'élection présidentielle n'était pas
n'était pas du tout à l'image du
comportement des députés à l'A nationale
enfin c'était il a été très comme
d'habitude très pédagogique sur les
plateaux il était sur son habit de
sénateur on va dire qu'il a été quand
même pendant 30 ans il est il sait être
je dirais un homme de la République
française mais il sait aussi sans
écarter ou quand il décide de son
écarter et là il a très clairement
choisi d'être dans une position de
colère et de rupture et il recommence
sur la colère et la rupture à l'égard de
tous ses partenaires à l'égard des
journaux des journalistes la dernière
toujours été plus ou moins pendant
laquelle pendant la nuit
exactement pendant la campagne des
présidentielles des témoins désagréable
tandis que la dernière émission de sur
BFM il est arrivé la première minute il
a commencé à engueuler tout le plateau
quoi il n'était pas assis que c'était
déjà la crise donc je veux dire c'est on
voit bien qu'il est dans des dans
vraiment dans des oscillations qui
correspondent et à ses hésitations et à
son appréciation du moment c'est à dire
ce qu'il pense être l'état d'esprit du
pays comment ils pensent qu'il doit le
représenter à ce moment là il sait bien
que l'élection présidentielle il faut
être crédible et là il pense que le pays
est en colère et en éruption qu'il est
on est au bord de d'une révolution en
France et que donc lui se veut être dans
cette dans en situation d'être présent à
dans ce cas-là je sais pas si la raison
mais en tout cas c'est ça son son
impression je rappelle le score de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon au premier tour de
cette présidentielle c'était il y a un
peu plus de 10 mois 7 millions 800 000
voix près de 7 millions 800 00021,95%
des voix est-ce qu'on peut dire Frédéric
salviki que il a dilapidé cet espoir où
est-ce que c'était une faux un faux
score parce que il y a eu beaucoup de de
on va dire de vote par par défaut ou de
vote efficace de la part des électeurs
de gauche oui je me suis déjà le cas en
2017 donc
vous souvenez qu'entre 2017 et 2022 LFI
a eu beaucoup de contre-performance
électorales qui ont suivi et néanmoins
Jean-Luc Mélenchon et c'est aussi comme
ça que ce s'imagine disons la situation
beaucoup de son entourage a quand même
réussi à faire mieux que il avait fait
en 2017 donc finalement et après la
République c'est moi pardon
sur ce plateau on aurait dit l'avenir de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon on peut disons
trouver un certain nombre de raisons qui
font que ils pensent que cette stratégie
alternative entre une fois on pourrait
dire le tribunal populiste et puis
plutôt le rassembleur de la gauche et
quelque chose qui finalement ne nuit pas
à son capital électoral bon alors
aujourd'hui la situation est différente
parce que c'est d'abord ça serait ça
serait il a déjà été candidats on l'a
rappelé trois fois une quatrième fois il
a pris de l'âge il est plus en position
au Parlement d'être le porte-parole
officiel finalement dans les des dans
les dans les débats et malgré malgré
tout il a même si c'est sur un capital
électoral faible il a redonné des
couleurs
assez partenaires c'est à dire que les
écologistes n'auraient pas eu un groupe
d'une vingtaine de députés s'il y avait
pas eu l'accord de laupestres je ne suis
pas sûr que les socialistes aient réussi
à sauver bon ça peut se discuter un
groupe de 30 les communistes etc donc et
ça a été la condition du rassemblement
maintenant effectivement
j'allais dire c'est parti sont beaucoup
plus qui ne l'était en 2017 en situation
de lui contester le leadership et bon je
pense que la la le caractère
cyclothymique de ses positions vise à
réasseoir à chaque fois finalement ça
suprématie et il faut dire que pour
l'instant on a évoqué des nombres enfin
on voit pas très bien aujourd'hui à
gauche y compris au sein du Parti
socialiste quel que soit les vérités de
Bernard Cazeneuve on peut pas dire que
ça déchaîne les comment dire
l'engouement même s'il y a quelques
Présidents de Conseils généraux ou maire
de ville socialistes qui s'y rattachent
enfin on voit bien qu'il y a quand même
un vide quoi on voit pas on a du mal à
imaginer qui homme ou femme pourrait
dire heureusement c'est dans quatre ans
mais bon bah non parce qu'une
présidentielle ça se passe on va dire
Emmanuel Macron a réussi ce hold-up en
s'y préparant deux ans à l'avance mais
enfin vu la situation situation
politique très fragile dans laquelle et
la gauche vu la nécessité quand même
dans laquelle elle serait de proposer un
projet crédible et rassembleur bah on
voit pas très très bien effectivement
qui pourrait encore aujourd'hui lui
faire de l'ombre donc je n'entrerai pas
forcément trop vite Jean-Luc Mélenchon
non pas à cause de ses qualités
intrinsèques mais aussi à cause de
l'extrême faiblesse et division des
autres parties et on a vu que les
parties socialistes avaient pas vraiment
donné l'exemple du rassemblement quant
aux écologistes on peut leur faire
confiance quand même sur leur grande
capacité aussi à continuer de se
déchirer il y a que le Parti communiste
qui est réussi à rassembler derrière le
leader mais enfin on imagine
difficilement Roussel pouvant
disons incarner un rassemblement à
gauche dans la perspective
présidentielle je pense quand même que
la question de l'avenir de l'après
Mélenchon est une question ouverte c'est
à dire qu'elle de toute façon elle est
ouverte par nécessité que ça nous plaise
ou pas nous sommes mortels et même lui
donc il y a un moment donné ça va
s'arrêter cette affaire donc il va bien
falloir qu'il y ait une suite et je
pense quand même qu'un certain nombre de
gens s'y préparent et cette stratégie de
se préparer à la suite je pense qu'ils
intègrent le fait qu'il va faut
rassembler toute la gauche c'est à dire
que quand on voit le positionnement de
François Ruffin ou de Clémentine Autain
on voit bien que il a passé une petite
étape encore cette semaine en étant un
peu plus précise sur l'ambition
présidentielle de leur point de vue
c'est aussi à qui il s'adresse parce que
je veux dire c'est que quand François
refuin dit je suis social-démocrate en
fait social et démocrate ça veut pas
dire qu'il est socialiste évidemment
mais néanmoins il a fait un clin d'oeil
assez fort assez appuyé au-delà des
rives de la France insoumise Clémentine
Autain elle fait aussi elle fait ses
appels du côté des féministes et elles
vont voilà on peut dire que l'un et
l'autre cherche à dépasser
le les frontières de la France insoumise
pour préparer une alternative à Jean-Luc
Mélenchon en 2027 aussi évidemment une
question de d'espace politique alors
Jean-Luc Mélenchon il a depuis 24 heures
rajoutées à la liste de ses alliés
exaspéré on va dire ça comme ça la
sénatoriale moi je suis pas sûr que ils
étaient pas déjà un peu exaspéré avant
mais bref le conseil politique des
insoumis a appelé solennellement les
sénateurs de la nupa je les cite un tout
faire pour empêcher l'adoption de la
retraite à 64 ans réaction de la
sénatrice socialiste de l'Oise Laurence
Rossignol sur Twitter voilà ce qui nous
manquait pour le débat retraite les
consignes de LFI au sénateur de gauche
au Sénat enigot à l'ancienne
heureusement qu'ils sont là pour nous
dire de nous opposer on y aurait pas
penser nous-mêmes manuel Bompard
coordinateur de LFI à tenté de déminer
c'était lors d'une conférence de prière
soit en l'écoute la France insoumise n'a
pas de groupe au Sénat et donc nous
pensons que puisque nous sommes dans une
alliance qui s'appelle la nupes et que
les trois autres composantes politiques
qui participent de la nups ont des
groupes au Sénat il est de notre
responsabilité de leur indiquer quelle
est notre regard sur la situation et il
s'agit pas de donner des leçons à qui
que ce soit chaque groupe au Sénat est
autonome et il prendra les décisions
qu'il l'entend alors bon on va aller à
la source grâce à Tam traduis qui peut
nous sur ce plateau bonsoir Tam et
bienvenue puisque vous l'avez nous
expliquer comment la gauche sénatoriale
va s'opposer à cette réforme des
retraites
fermement frontalement au projet du
gouvernement qui est soutenu au Sénat
par la droite et le centre mais sa
stratégie elle sera bien plus mesurée
que celle que l'on a pu voir à
l'Assemblée nationale à l'Assemblée
rappelez-vous il y avait eu 20 000
amendements qui avaient été déposé
attendez-vous à quasiment 10 fois moins
au Sénat puisque les trois groupes de
gauche socialistes écologistes
communistes prévoient de déposer autour
de 1500 2000 amendements auxquels il
faudra aussi ajouter quelques centaines
d'amendements de la part de la droite et
du centre et en plus de ça ils vont
aussi défendre toutes les motion de
procédure possible et prévues ce sont
les moments où les groupes demandent à
ce que le texte ne soit pas débattu soit
parce qu'il le juge par exemple
contraire à la Constitution ou soit
parce que par exemple il demande un
référendum et bien ces motion Elle va
être tout à tour défendues par les
groupes les deux mis à jour d'examen
mais il n'y a absolument aucun suspense
elles vont être rejetées et donc le
Sénat va ensuite débattre du projet de
loi et ça fera plaisir au leader
syndicaux le Sénat va enfin débattre de
l'article 7 l'article central de cette
réforme de l'opposition ne veulent pas
du tout du scénario qui s'est déroulé au
Palais Bourbon ils veulent à tout prix
débattre du report de l'âge légal de
départ à la retraite à 64 ans et ils
vont pour cela et bien coordonner leur
action d'ailleurs la semaine prochaine
ils annoncent déjà une fée conférence de
presse commune qui aura lieu d'ailleurs
mercredi car il faut dire qu'il faut
aussi viser finement il faut débattre de
l'article 7 mais après la mobilisation
du 7 mars c'est ça tout l'enjeu la
mobilisation du 7 mars cette grande
journée de blocage qui est déjà annoncé
par les syndicats depuis plusieurs
semaines la gauche natoriale ne veut
surtout pas que l'article 7 soit débattu
est vraisemblablement adopté par le
Sénat ou je le rappelle la majorité du
droit et du centre et bien vote le
report de l'âge déjà depuis cinq ans
dans l'hémicycle ils veulent pas donc
qu'il y ait l'adoption de ce texte avant
que ce qui s'annonce comme une
démonstration de force vous imaginez
bien sûr le coût que ça ferait au moral
des troubles dans la rue si l'article
contre lequel il se battent est adopté
avant que les cortèges se mettent en
marche et surtout les sénateurs de
gauche veulent pour la plupart ne pas
aller jusqu'au bout du texte ils ne
veulent pas de vote finale il devrait
donc aussi utiliser toutes les armes
possibles pour ralentir ensuite l'examen
du projet de loi outre les amendements
où vous avez bien les prises de parole
vous avez les rappels au règlement vous
avez les demandes de scrutin public bref
ils vont faire de l'obstruction plus
soft qu'à l'Assemblée mais de
l'obstruction quand même est-ce qu'ils
vont arriver à leur fin de pas voter sur
l'ensemble du texte alors franchement
j'ai pas de boule de cristal j'y mettrai
pas ma main à couper le gouvernement et
la majorité sénatoriale ont aussi leur
disposition des outils en revanche pour
accélérer le débat par exemple en 2010
lors de l'examen de la réforme des
retraites qui avait permis de reporter
l'âge légal de départ de 60 à 62 ans le
gouvernement avait fini par utiliser la
procédure du vote bloqué le débat au
Sénat c'était enlisé sur trois semaines
et le gouvernement avait fini par
demander au sénateur de ce prononcer par
un seul vote sur la fin du texte en ne
retenant que les amendements qu'ils
voulaient et ça c'est encore possible
sur ce texte vous avez aussi les armes à
la main de la majorité sénatoriale par
exemple l'article 38 du Règlement du
Sénat qui permet d'écourter très
fortement les débats en obligeant à
voter sur un article ou un texte même à
main levée et ça seulement après que
l'orateur de l'opposition aura appris la
parole enfin il faut deux orateurs de
l'opposition qui prennent la parole vous
avez aussi encore un autre article on a
regardé tout le règlement du Sénat c'est
l'article 47.2 qui permet d'attribuer un
temps défini à chaque groupe bref il y a
tous les outils techniques à disposition
pour faire adopter ce projet de loi mais
il y a une donnée qui ne figure nulle
part dans le règlement du Sénat c'est
l'effet qu'aurait le Rec à ses
procédures sur les nombreux Français
opposés à la réforme est-ce que là cela
ne risque pas d'envenimer la situation
bref heureusement la politique et bien
ce n'est pas seulement de la technique
et de la guérilla parlementaire merci
beaucoup tant pour toutes ces
explications des rentrées effectivement
dans le dans les arcanes du
fonctionnement de du Sénat et ça nous
projette vers ce que sera notre antenne
dans les dans les jours où les 11 jours
où le texte sera examiné puisque on va
vraiment donner une large part à
l'examen de ce texte parce qu'elle
Perrineau ça va faire du bien peut-être
de parler du fond on peut aussi dire ça
ça va faire du bien certainement de
parler du fond et ça va faire du bien
aussi de voir une assemblée
parlementaire arriver à nouer un débat
démocratique ce qui n'a pas été le cas à
l'Assemblée nationale où l'Assemblée
nationale a été transformé j'allais dire
en lieu de guérilla et pas nouveau c'est
déjà arrivé dans notre Histoire
parlementaire oui bien sûr c'est pas la
première fois avec beaucoup plus
d'abandonnements l'ange d'amendement etc
mais là il y avait une certaine
j'allais dire attitude de nombre de
députés de LFI qui montrait
véritablement qu'il n'en avait rien à
cirer de ce lieu de la représentation
nationale qu'est l'Assemblée nationale
le recours aux injures
étaient en particulier tout même
montrait que une partie de ce personnel
n'a pas l'habitude d'être dans des
assemblées élues et fonctionne donc avec
complètement d'autres réactions un autre
logiciel ils ne savent pas très bien ce
que c'est que de représenter le peuple
et il considère assez souvent quand vous
écoutez parfois certains jeunes députés
de LFI que la véritable démocratie au
fond c'est la rue ça n'est pas une
assemblée élue et je crois que pour
essayer de bien comprendre cette culture
de éléphant il faut bien comprendre que
dans la gauche française il y a
plusieurs cultures et il y a une culture
en particulier qu'on pourrait appeler
mouvementiste qui considère que au fond
le lieu essentiel de la démocratie ce
sont les manifestations c'est la rue ça
n'est pas du tout l'Assemblée nationale
ou le Sénat on connaît ça d'ailleurs
dans j'allais dire ce que le marxisme
distinguait jadis quand il distinguait
la démocratie formelle et la démocratie
réelle au fond le lieu des assemblées
cela démocratie formelle ça n'est pas
très intéressant il y a des lieux qui
sont beaucoup plus significatifs de ce
qu'ils appelaient la démocratie la
démocratie réelle et je crois que chez
Mélenchon chez nombre de députés de la
France insoumise c'est là qu'il y a
cette culture qu'on ne retrouve pas du
tout de la même manière parmi les élus
socialistes on a vu les réactions des
élus socialistes ou même parmi les élus
écologistes et ça pose évidemment la
question de la du fonctionnement
démocratique du parti elle est fille
lui-même question posée par
clémentinottin tiens regardé à la Une de
Libération elle fait partie de celles et
ceux qui demande plus de démocratie à la
France insoumise elle l'avait également
exprimé sur France Info on écoute la
députée de Seine-Saint-Denis je pense
qu'il faut avancer vers davantage de
délibération collective il faut donner
plus de moyens au groupe d'action et il
faut faire vivre un état d'esprit qui
est l'état d'esprit du plus réaliste
donc c'est pas le cas aujourd'hui je
pense qu'on peut progresser clairement
oui on peut progresser sur ces sujets
Catherine tricot est-ce que on l'a
évoqué mais très vite est-ce que
l'affaire katnas a été une rupture
interne au sein du parti LFI je le crois
pas seulement pour l'objet lui-même
c'est-à-dire que c'est aussi Jean-Luc
Mélenchon a exigé un absolu discipline
autour de sa position c'est-à-dire que
il je pense qu'il n'a pas compris le
moment politique le moment social il ne
comprend pas qu'il n'est plus possible
de soutenir comme il l'a fait un député
qui file débat face à sa femme ça paraît
pas possible mais il n'a pas compris que
des députés disent non ça c'est le point
de limite on ne le fera pas et donc là
Jean-Luc Mélenchon il exige une absolue
fidélité à ses ordres et je voudrais
revenir un instant sur ce qui s'est
passé cette semaine de que raconte le
Figaro c'est que mardi les députés de la
France insoumise avaient voté
majoritairement pour retirer leurs
amendements de façon à ce qu'on puisse
aller à la discussion de l'article 7
mais très majoritairement et Jean-Luc
Mélenchon n'en a pas été satisfait donc
il a fait reconvoquer le groupe pour
obtenir un nouveau vote qui a inversé
jusqu'à ce que vous soyez d'accord avec
moi grosso modo exactement et ben ça ça
n'est pas possible quoi je veux dire je
pense que c'est c'est l'affaire catenens
elle est révélatrice aussi de quelqu'un
qui dirige de l'extérieur mais qui
dirige d'une main de fer et on est avec
moi où on est contre moi c'est-à-dire
Jean-Luc Mélenchon est quand même
quelqu'un qui exige absolu fidélité en
politique ça ne peut pas fonctionner
comme ça parce que on est dans un moment
compliqué donc il y a besoin d'avoir une
certaine liberté il faut que ça puisse
respirer il faut que ça puisse discuter
si ça ne discute pas ça va forcément
dans le ravin à un moment donné quand
bien même Jean-Luc Mélenchon serait
super génial il est forcément on ne peut
pas diriger seul une organisation et
prétendre en plus diriger un pays comme
la France simplement sur une technique
je dirais d'un autoritarisme comme celle
qu'il fait
qu'il pratique se débarrasser de ses
plus fidèles soutient comme enfin
Coquerel Corbières concret des garridos
sont quand même notamment Garrido et
Corbières étaient avec eux au Parti
socialiste c'est le point de rupture ah
mais c'est accroît franchement c'est
incroyable ce qui vient de se passer et
ce sont des gens qui ont qui l'ont
accompagné dans toute sa dans toute sa
ces batailles et là d'un seul coup il
leur a dit dehors je veux dire ils ont
totalement surpris
et même à l'égard de ses plus proches il
exige absolu fidélité et si il y a le
moindre doute
non parce que moi je pense c'est que il
y avait quand même un sens politique là
pour moi ça ne fait pas sens politique
voilà ce que je veux dire c'est que il y
a quelque chose d'absurde à imaginer
qu'on peut devenir président de la
République Premier ministre chef de
l'opposition en se comportant de cette
manière à l'égard de tous un mot rapide
oui extrêmement rapide c'est vrai que ça
semble complètement absurde son attitude
mais enfin quand vous regardez les
cultures partisanes des différentes
formations de la gauche de la gauche il
y a beaucoup plus d'organisation qui
sont des organisations autoritaires qui
fonctionnent au culte du chef que
d'organisation que d'organisation à
écouter aussi
pendant des années c'était pas le lieu
même de la démocratie partisane et les
filles au fond
de la personnalisation
[Musique]
les modèles on le citait tout à l'heure
les modèles de Jean-Luc Mélenchon sont
eux-mêmes tout à fait particuliers
Chavez Castro je veux dire on est on
n'est pas au coeur d'une démocratie
pluraliste
Frédéric savity il y a un bon un autre
exemple qui était cité je crois que
c'était par nos confrères du Parisien
Aujourd'hui en France qui raconte
l'histoire de la journée du 16 février
il y a un meeting de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
à Montpellier qui qui est financé par
EFI et le même jour et qui est organisé
c'est ça qui est important le même jour
à la même heure que le meeting de
clémentinotta
OTA Corbières etc qui lui sera pas
financé par le parti donc enfin voilà
c'est c'est c'est quoi c'est la
démonstration que les filles
d'abord
qu'on parle de culture partisane mais
dans le cas de LFI il y a pas de culture
partisane parce que pour l'instant il y
a pas de partie c'est que c'est presque
revendiqué on a une organisation
j'ai un trait la bile qui est
essentiellement une société de cours
c'est comme ça que ça c'est construit
autour de la personnalité de Mélenchon
qui apporte tout le crédit ou
l'essentiel du crédit au parti puisque
c'est grâce à son score élection
présidentielle que derrière il peut y
avoir des députés élus derrière il peut
avoir des financements etc et donc elle
est fille a refusé après 2017 de
s'institutionnaliser c'est-à-dire
d'adopter des procédures pour désigner
les représentants d'abord les candidats
aux élections ensuite les dirigeants du
parti a refusé de créer des sections ou
l'équivalent en tout cas d'une
organisation territoriale avec des
délégués et puis voilà il y a pas il y a
pas véritable ronde de congrès au sein
desquels on tranche les questions
programmatiques doctrinales bon voilà
donc c'est ça qui est en jeu aujourd'hui
c'est à dire que la nouvelle en tout cas
la nouvelle génération parce qu'ils sont
souvent quand même beaucoup plus jeunes
que Mélenchon exigent c'est ce que
disait que Clémentine Autain une
démocratie qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ça
veut pas forcément dire une démocratie
directe loin de là il y a pas beaucoup
de parties qui fonctionnent comme ça
mais au moins des procédures des
procédures électives où on vote pas
simplement qu'à malvé au coup par coup
et on revote quand le résultat est pas
bon et on sache exactement comment sont
désignés les dirigeants on a vu que la
direction qui a été constituée récemment
il y a un mois et demi en fait
n'obéissez pas à des procédures on a
exclu certains dans la garder d'autres
on sait pas très bien qui a le droit de
vote donc c'est de ça dont il est
question aujourd'hui c'est comment une
organisation essentiellement personnelle
va réussir ou non à se transformer en un
parti politique c'est-à-dire en une
organisation qui va survivre à son
fondateur ou son créateur à son parler
de gourou son prophète son leader
charismatique peu importe comment on
appelle ça donc le problème de Mélenchon
mais Jean-Marie Le Pen a eu du mal à
céder aussi à sa fille autre leader très
personnel c'est effectivement d'accepter
de ne plus être ce qu'il était en Incas
intéressant en Italie avec le mouvement
5 étoiles où on a le gourou si on peut
dire qu'il lui n'a jamais été élu PP
grille et il reste il s'est petit à
petit retiré mais il a joué un rôle de
sage c'est un peu ce que aurait pu faire
mais lorsqu'on avait imaginer
la France il y a une élection
présidentielle le suffrage universelle
direct et que Mélenchon au bout du
compte reste persuadé que c'est lui le
meilleur à pouvoir rassembler et qui a
personne aujourd'hui qui puisse me faire
deux il nous reste quoi 5 minutes
dernier chapitre dans ce débat les
relations très fraîches entre le leader
le chef des insoumis les leaders
syndicaux la réforme des retraites on le
sait offre à Jean-Luc Mélenchon une
tribune tient justement je parlais de ce
meeting de Montpellier on a choisi un
extrait de ce meeting Jean-Luc Mélenchon
écoute
nos enfants ne sont pas seulement en
train de se battre pour la dignité de
leur grand-parents qui arrivent à la
limite où il pensait pouvoir
bénéficier à la Maison du fruit de leurs
efforts car nous l'oublions jamais une
retraite n'est pas un cadeau la retraite
c'est ce que vous avez cotisé toute
votre vie pour les autres et les autres
cotisent pour vous
regardez cette petite prétentieux notre
bon maître qui nous parle avec sa badine
à la main il n'y a pas de système aussi
généreux qu'en France et ben pas à cause
de toi mon pauvre grâce au lutte qu'on a
mené parce que jamais vous avez rien
donné sans la lutte
voilà Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui parlait
évidemment du président de la République
mais alors on peut il y a un vrai talent
de tribun ça c'est sûr et c'est pas et
on se demande qui dans les successeurs
potentiels homme ou femme politique
pourrait avoir ce talent de tribunal
bref on suivra ça sur la relation ça me
permettait d'ouvrir le débat sur le la
partie retraite et les relations avec
les leaders syndicaux Pascal Perino
est-ce qu'il y a pas finalement
une espèce de contraste là entre voilà
le bruit et la fureur je reprends la
formule la tonalité des débats à
l'Assemblée nationale et puis et les
divisions dont on parle depuis le début
de de débat et puis l'unité syndicale
l'Inter syndicale qui fait la preuve de
son unité qui fait la preuve qui qui
organise des manifestations qui se
déroulent dans le calme ce qui était pas
arrivé depuis très longtemps dans notre
pays donc ça aussi en creux ça isole un
peu plus Jean-Luc Mélenchon bien sûr
parce que le tempérament de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon et ce qu'il représente c'est
c'est pas une culture très très
favorable à ce qu'on pourrait appeler
l'autonomie syndicale l'indépendance
syndicale il considère quelque part que
le mouvement social c'est lui qu'il doit
jouer un rôle tout à fait essentiel dans
ce qu'on appelle maintenant le le
mouvement social et que quelque part il
y a voilà à côté des syndicats peut-être
même d'ailleurs devant les syndicats il
y a Jean-Luc Mélenchon et la France
insoumise et donc on assiste depuis des
semaines maintenant à cette espèce de
chicaya mais invraisemblable au niveau
des agendas entre l'agenda de Mélenchon
et de la France insoumise et l'agenda du
mouvement social dirigé par les
syndicats et on comprend que ça exaspère
littéralement les leaders syndicaux qui
sont tout de même quand on regarde les
manifestations la composition des
manifestations qui sont tout de même les
entrepreneurs essentiels de la réussite
ou non des des manifestations donc là il
y a certainement une culture qui est
assez allergique à l'autonomie syndicale
les syndicales d'accord à condition que
ça tout de même obéisse à Jean-Luc
Mélenchon Catherine tricot qu'est-ce qui
peut faire maintenant parce que c'est
une période intéressante qui qui s'ouvre
puisque les débats vont avoir lieu au
Sénat Jean-Luc mélench envoyer Déjà pas
présent à l'assemblée mais bon voilà ça
ça stratégie consistait à utiliser ces
troupes à l'Assemblée pour finalement
donner le ton ou le la du calendrier
politique parlementaire qu'est-ce qui
peut faire là moi pour l'instant je sais
pas ce qu'il peut faire ce que je note
c'est qu'il y a un appel à la
radicalisation entre guillemets du
mouvement qui me paraît très
problématique parce qu'elle va contre
justement la recherche d'unités et
d'élargissement du mouvement qui est
demandé par les syndicats et par les
autres parties de gauche c'est à dire
qu'en fait il y a une question de
d'analyse qu'est-ce qui est le plus fort
est-ce que c'est beaucoup beaucoup de
monde dans toutes les dans toutes les
couches sociales de la société dans
toutes les villes de toutes les villes
c'est ce qu'on dit souvent notamment
dans les villes moyennes
un mouvement très fort et très large
ancré ou est-ce que c'est la
radicalisation elle a peut-être à la
gilet jaune et donc en fait il y a un
petit peu ce débat et moi je que je ce
que j'entends et ce que je vois y
compris par la manifestation qu'ils ont
eu à la fin du vote vendredi où ils ont
descendu les marches de l'Assemblée en
chantant le chant des gilets jaunes
c'est qu'en fait ce que Mélenchon à en
tête c'est il le dit sans arrêt il faut
radicaliser le mouvement moi je crois
qu'il n'en a pas le pouvoir je ne crois
pas que ce je pense que c'est contre
l'opinion de des syndicats et j'espère
que ça ne marchera pas parce que je
crois que ça c'est une impasse qui nous
mettrait dans une situation
insensée quoi c'est à dire qu'on va on
va dans un ça ne veut pas dire qu'on va
pas à l'échec du mouvement mais l'échec
du mouvement ne se rend contre balancera
pas par un par des une insurrection qui
sera battue je veux dire l'état n'est
pas au bord de tomber en France un mot
de conclusion enfin avec sa Viki sur la
bataille de l'opinion on peut dire que
le gouvernement la relativement perdu
depuis
depuis plusieurs semaines mais peut-être
que Jean-Luc Mélenchon l'a perdu aussi
oui c'est à dire que ce qui est on n'a
pas le temps d'en parler on n'a pas
beaucoup parlé du rassemblement national
mais en embuscade lorsqu'on regarde des
enquêtes aujourd'hui finalement c'est
plutôt Marine Le Pen et le rassemblement
national qui est la discrétion
c'est la question évidemment des n'est
pas là et
l'autre point quand même qu'on appelle
le temps d'aborder c'est que une des
faiblesses de la nupes qui qui
effectivement n'existe comme un accord
électoral et n'a pas réussi à par
exemple se doter du fameux Parlement de
la nupes ou à créer une structure
pérenne de discussion d'échanges enfin
bon peu importe n'est pas identifié
aujourd'hui comme porteuse d'un projet
alternatif
sur la question des retraites et manière
plus générale en matière sociale
économique environnementale il y a
énormément de travail à faire et le
risque effectivement c'est que tout ce
brouha si on peut dire ou c'est
diversions
face perdre de vue à la fois cet
objectif ne permette pas aux Français
les plus mobilisés d'identifier
clairement la nups comme porteuse d'une
alternative il y a crédible sur le plan
politique électoral à moyen terme merci
beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir participé
à ce débat je rappelle le titre de la
rue du Regard Catherine tricot Occident
échec et mythe voilà proposé évidemment
à trouver dans les Kios merci beaucoup à
bientôt sur ce plateau